ain't no defund the police the reality
is you have seen a major increase in
funding of police Democrats
years ago that's a flat out lie there
were individuals that with a straight
look on yourself right now I have
actually talked directly who came up
with defund the police who came up with
the activists did reactive and activists
were Republicans Or democrats they were
activists first of all they hate both
parties you don't even talk to them but
I do but the Democrats in Congress were
repeating it no no no no no no no no no
no no no sorry stop stop AOC who else
you said the Democrats in Congress how
many Democrats in Congress oppose defund
the police a lot but I'm saying there
were so some in conversations
hell I could quote Louis goldmert and
some crazy stuff that he says and go
well you know what that's Republicans
the reality is this here Democrats
Democratic Mayors Democratic Governors
and yes Democratic president have
greatly increased is funding of police
in this country ain't even a question
so we can how you can holler but
Democrats defund the police when it
shows they've actually increased the
show the video they've increased them
you asked for it yeah you asked for it
show the video which video now
show the video I just emailed you I just
texted you because
Charles Barkley Democrats haven't said
they phoned the police at all because
they would never say that no you said
Democrats haven't said that activists
said that your word no no you said who
created the phrase I said it was who
said who supported that created who came
up with the concept of defunding the
police activists did and then which
credible Democrats there were some
Democrats no not some no these are some
heavy duties
when Democrats control Congress how many
votes they had there you go
when Democrats control Congress Nancy
Pelosi when Democrats control Congress
how many votes they have
223 Democrats vote to defund the police
health issues or policing in schools and
all the rest that perhaps we can uh
Shuffle some of that money around suck
it up be fun and the police has to
happen we
won the policeman Eric Garcetti saying
take some of the money from policing
about 150 million dollars I applaud Eric
Garcetti for doing what he's done not
only do we need no no no no
[Music]
no you're wrong you're wrong do you do
you understand do you understand that in
a significant number of cities in this
country right where you have policing
who do everything okay you have in some
cities where the police are handing out
parking tickets where the police are
doing duties that they had nothing with
the streets when you say reallocate what
that says is okay why should we have
police handing out parking tickets why
don't we have them doing the major
function of fighting crime why don't we
actually have this unit that handles
that that's called reallocation when you
talk think about the issue of mental
illness no I'm not I'm standing fast
first of all it makes me both of you a
question if either one of you actually
covered City Hall before
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I'm giving you
don't you want facts here's the deal I
actually have been a city hall reporter
I have actually been in the city
meetings when you talk about why don't
you just say you were wrong
Democrats were wrong because I'm not
wrong because you're wrong
explain to me reallocation hold up Mr
CEO yeah when you're in a company and
when you reallocate funds from one unit
to the other are you cutting funding or
are you simply adjusting why do you have
a hard time just saying they said it why
do you have a hard time by the way I can
actually allow three people if you allow
words if you allowed it you would have
heard them saying defund the police who
I literally wait a minute I literally
heard Nance bullets they Shuffle I heard
Kamala Harris say reallocate you go oh
that's defund you actually have a
reallocation of resources that exist in
city government County government state
government federal government every
single day but for some reason you don't
want to deal with that was it spin when
I told you that Democratic Mayors and
governors in the president they've
greatly increased police funding while
kick hold up can you acknowledge that as
a fact you
if I sit with you and you can
acknowledge can you acknowledge the fact
and you can acknowledge that your side
of the Party Support it see this right
there see you're yelling your side I'm
not yelling my side independent here's
the whole deal though I first of all
again first of all in Texas you I don't
have to register as anything you you
still you still are not going to
acknowledge the fact that the defund the
police concept was brought up by acting
constantly reaffirmed by some of the
most powerful Democrats in America the
Speaker of the House saying in America
shuffling of funds that is not defunding
if you if you would the vice president
Kamala Harris said reallocation that is
not but ilhan Omar said not only defund
you said dismantle
um
that's one member of Congress right oh
but you want to let you know there's a
seven minute video
first of all show me here's the deal
show me 218 who defended that and
actually voted for it to happen please
you can't you know why stop because they
see this is this is where credibility is
lost we're talking about credibility is
lost if this is utterly hilarious I am
stating I understand Democratic mayors
Democratic Governors Democratic
president your voice doesn't validate
your argument increased funding mayor
Lori Lightfoot of Chicago to
20 minutes of the police department to
deal with the mental issues that they
were having oh I'm sorry is that
reallocation maybe one of the worst
places
money and reallocate it for that oh but
reallocation works when you agree with
it what I'm trying to explain to you is
when you say deeply Watkins cut you can
you can see fun means do you remember
earlier when I said there's a difference
between persuasion and manipulation you
can spin any argument you're very good
at debating you're very good at raising
your voice interrupting all that stuff
I've watched you for years I think it's
hilarious but what that both of you will
say that the Democratic party yeah has
supported defund the police win the best
they supported when the fact that the
Democratic party came up with the idea
you're wrong and they supported it
you're actually not heard Republicans
say defund the police you've not heard
actually you're actually wrong incentive
Tim Scott's policing bill that he
released in 2021 in the bill I will
happily send it to you what did he say
he actually said what did he say I want
to hear it no I'm gonna read hold on let
me guess he said reallocate no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's not what
he said
because see what you don't understand is
but here's what no no no when the drug
lord Justice La the entire on the George
floor just as like the entire I
literally said this I sent this to
Senator Tim Scott and he didn't answer
my question when we were running for
office and I answered yes to that
question we are going to reduce funding
in the police department and redirect
there's no reduced funding
[Music]
growing what did they do
we propose Elise Cuts was a good one
million dollars
that wasn't a sheet that was a guy a
million yeah
no more policing depends police cuts are
a good thing in these communities if
they not donate jobs oh my God
right here no no no you say to me you
said oh show me Republican when Senator
Tim Scott introduced his bill
okay on police reform this is one of the
things that he did when it failed last
year he went on Margaret Brennan's show
CBS Face the Nation he said the
Democrats wanted to defund the police
and that was a bridge too far in Senator
Tim Scott's own bill they actually said
in order for police to qualify for these
funds laws would have to be passed on
the city of the state level
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
oh my God so you buy that into defund
the police
you won't even listen buddy if there's
anybody who doesn't listen you listen
Senator Tim Scott said that they won't
get the funds if laws don't get passed
I'm telling you what he did he did a
year later calls that same thing respect
defund the police and I literally and if
you want to see it
those are the text messages you're so
funny I sent to Senator Tim Scott and I
said Senator Tim Scott please explain to
me the difference between what you said
the Democrats are doing what you did you
just hurt your argument even more
talking about because what you just did
is validated everybody else what they
just said no yes because that means what
Kamala said what Nancy Pelosi said
they're all saying the same thing
they've won the police what is and now
they realized it was a bad idea did not
say they found the police of course he
did not either oh oh wait a minute so
you say what accomplish said was this
your argument you just said yourself now
no I didn't you did no I didn't of
course you did no I was specifically
calling out Senator Tim Scott by trying
to call something defund the police when
they were simply proposing exactly you
know what he you know what's the problem
here's the problem Roland the problem is
when when I sat down when I sit down
with somebody with whatever thing they
believe in okay it's
specifically a lot on the Democratic
side ah it's specifically it is it is
being a Democrat before their country it
is how they vote before America it is
nope I'm gonna defend this because
there's no way there's these guys gonna
say anything wrong with defund the
police and and that's when you lose
credibility all you have to say is you
have no you acknowledge
support you that's all you have to say
you have no credibility on this when you
can't even acknowledge what reallocation
means you have no credibility when you
can't even Define that when I have
actually talked to Mayors and city
council members and they have walked
through how when London Bridge when the
policies
destroy the city first Democrats have
had to vote when the mayor when the
mayor of San Francisco talked about the
mental illness crisis in their
particular City and they said we need to
be sending mental health folks out on
calls and not always the cops now we've
seen numerous examples where that
happens what has actually happened in
the last 30 or 40 years in Democrat and
Republican cities and states in the
country we've seen a massive cut with
mental illness what is the greatest
increase of incidence I'm stating fact
what you don't like no but you refuse to
acknowledge knowledge or accept because
you're stuck on Democrats ahead of 53
years you acted I'm asking no no hold up
you act as if in those 53 years
Republicans have never had power you
actually Republicans have never had the
house or the senate or the white house
so here's the question I said to you
show me how the Republicans there's no
way to talk with you bro I gotta tell
you so show me how Republicans changed
so here's what I think give me examples
are you gonna let anybody speak I'm I'm
waiting for your example if you have 92
of an entire community's vote like the
evangelicals for 60 years that's
evangelicals evangelicals are also part
of that black vote if you have if you
have 92 percent you actually don't
understand Evangelical black evangelism
you have 92 percent
of the black vote for 59 years
59 years later 27 out of 30 cities
for crime are ran by democrats your
policies don't work and let me ask you
any questions people don't have to read
this I'm gonna do it if I let me finish
and I'll let you talk you either have to
consider new policies or the voters have
to consider a new party okay so if you
enjoyed this club you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold Signature Series
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color changing mug when you drink coffee
that lion turns into a real lion and
then we have hoodies with vitamin gold
on it the gold Signature Series hat
shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways we
have a lot of items they're selling out
if you want to take advantage the gold
Signature Series click here place your
order Sports your right taming gear and
tag us with the hashtag valuetainment
foreign
[Music]